- When most people go into a church,
they go in there to reflect or to pray.
Most people I think would admit
that music enhances that experience.
There is nothing as moving as the rumbling
of the lowest pitch pipes on the organ.
The entire room vibrates
with the the sound.
It's a magical feeling.
(light music)
OK, we can start.
I'm David Wyld.
I'm the managing director
of Henry Willis and Sons.
We are organ builders, and
we build, restore, repair
and tune pipe organs all over
the British Isles and beyond.
Henry Willis was born in 1821 in London
and set up his own company
as an organ builder in 1845.
He built some of the
largest and grandest organs
of the Victorian period.
Until the Industrial
Revolution, the pipe organ
was the most complex
mechanism ever devised.
The average pipe organ will have
up to 10,000 moving parts in it.
A pipe organ has pipes
which sound or speak
when air is blown through the mouth area.
The speaking length of the
pipe determines the pitch.
So, basically, the longer the
pipe, the lower the pitch.
The shorter the pipe,
the higher the pitch.
The firm has built somewhere
between two-and-a-half
and 3,000 organs in its
nearly 175 year history.
We still use exactly the same methods;
some of the equipment is more up-to-date,
but most of the work is hand work.
And we still use many
of the Victorian tools
that are still in the firm
right from the first days.
The skills involved is, there's casting,
there's the metal forming
and the soldering;
that's just for the pipe making.
There's the joinery skills
required to make wooden pipework.
That's real skill.
When I hear one of our organs
play in a big acoustic,
it can be very moving.
The larger organs have speaking pipes
from a quarter of an inch
long down to 32 feet long
across an entire tonal
and dynamic spectrum.
And there's no better feeling
than standing at an opening
recital of a new organ,
looking up at it, and
saying, "We made that."
(organ music)